When I got to the airport, finally,
this check, this girl who had to be 22,
you know, people come up to me sometimes, whatever I'm ready for it and.
I see them come. I see you coming by the way from like, you're not being sneaky.
You know, people think they're like keto and I, uh,
and the guy and this girl goes like this and I go, Hey.
And she says, beer pong. And I go,
well, what the is going to be happening at this point from now on what kind of
reaction am I going to have drum up?
She goes, beer pong. And I, and I say, huh?
And she says, I met you last night during beer pong.
And I say, no, not me. And she says,
yeah, it was you.
And everybody's listening.
And I'm sure some of those people are like this idiot. Got it wrong.
She does. Doesn't realize that that's the comedian.
And she maybe recognizes him that way.
And is confusing someone else's.
Jenky face playing beer pong. Maybe she was drunk.
And now she thinks crystal Chris D'Elia was playing beer pong with her.
Bye. By the way, there are some people that think that,
but the people who don't know who I am are looking at me
like, oh,
this guy doesn't want to seem like he was playing beer pong with a 22
year old. So now it looked like a creep.
She goes, beer pong, 22 year old. And I say, ha 39 year old. And she says,
MEChA last night, playing beer pong. And I say, okay, one may. And she says,
yeah, it was dude,
quit blowing my fake cover. It wasn't me. First of all,
I would never play beer pong, dude, if I drank.
Uh, first of all, I've never drank period ever. End of story. Full stop.
Do I like when people say that? No, but full stop.
Uh, I I've never drank. Okay. So I know I didn't play beer pong.
I w even if I did, if I drank every day, like a fish,
I would never play beer pong. I, you know why?
Cause I don't need a reason to drink.
If I'm going to drink, I'm just going to put the to.
My mouth and then ingest it in my body. You're not going to try and get a,
I got to get, I'm going to get harder. Give me all the alcohol,
put it inside me and let me be drunk as.
Beer pong. You know, I wouldn't even play ping pong. How about that?
You're gonna give me a paddle. Now this low thing. No way, dude.
The only thing I paddle should be is on,
is connected to a key to get into a gas.
Uh, gas, uh, station bathroom.
You ever see the prank on YouTube. I don't know who it is,
but it's some show where they put the keys on funny things in a gas station.
And that one time they, and they kept putting on like big gas things.
And the person had to like bring the big thing.
And the last one was they put the key on a cat and they were like, here you go.
And the guy had to carry the cat to an undo. The key was attached to the cats,
um, color. And he had to undo the thing and then with the cat holding the cat,
man. That was hilarious. But guess what?
It still wasn't as funny as Brian, Callan's Instagram where he says,
I'm the man dragon dude. I did that. I put the, I put that up last night. Holy,
man. Let's play it.
Cause that Brian Callan is the biggest idiot of all time.
I can't even believe this moron, dude. Let's go to his thing.
Okay. Like, let me just hear it. Is
this okay? So
I was eating with my buddies. All right.
And Brian Collins shows up and we're all eating together. And then he leaves,
oh, we all leave. Right. And we're all laughing outside of the diner as we do.
We laugh outside of the diner because once you eat and you're done,
it's not over.
The fat lady hasn't sung yet you go outside and you th you know,
you do the thing, right?
Oh man, uh, you.
Do that. Yeah, dude, because I'm almost 40. You do that. You go, oh, uh, some.
Gets a toothpick. Cause he thinks he needs it. You know? And.
Oh man. So, and somebody says like, Hey, by the way,
and it goes like, nah, nah, you do that. You know? And he goes, ah.
That's hilarious. [inaudible] I don't know, man. Yeah.
And I was.
In there, you know?
And so Kalin leaves because he likes to be,
he loves to pretend like he has to do at 3:00 AM.
Even though he doesn't and he leaves and he gets, goes,
walks over to his car and this happens. Okay,
let me just pull it up again so I can play it from,
from the beginning of this happens. So he's far away.
Me and my other two buddies, the Irish guy and Craig.
Yo, Hey, that's me obviously.
What's up Brian? Good luck guys. You're a. Huh?
Huh? You're a. Hey bro, stay there. I'm going to tell you. Okay.
So he's far away now. He drives over his car is silent.
His Tesla rolls over like it's a kitty cat. Okay. Pulls up.
I'm shooting and I'm good.
Bro. Yeah. Tonight my comedy. This is what I do.
Crowd's ready that you know why they call me the man dragons.
[inaudible].
One does this, you turn illegally,
drives away, zips by and then has to stop at a red light.
Dude.
Let me tell you something right now.
There's nothing that's ever been funnier than that. Okay. He's 52
bro. He's 52
go to my Instagram page and you can see it. It's the last thing I posted.
He just goes one. That one. God.
He's funny, man.